hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my Supergirl season 2 video just
explaining what's going on because now
it's part of the CW universe they move
Supergirl to CW officially there's a
whole bunch of stuff going on there's
also some really cool Captain Cold stuff
happening next year but I'll explain
that at the end of this just because
it's a little bit different from the
Supergirl stuff but here's the deal with
Supergirl it has been renewed for season
two the whole reason that it's moving to
the CW involves the audience that
actually watched it there were a lot of
people that watched it but not
necessarily the people that CBS wanted
to watch it and money CBS had to pay a
huge license fee to Warner Brothers
because Warner Brothers television
studios produces it through Greg
Berlanti group because it's produced by
the same people that make flash arrow
legends of tomorrow but CBS itself
didn't own the show so we'd had to pay a
lot of extra money on top of the normal
budget one way that a lot of the shows
on the CW not just the DC shows but all
the shows on the CW save money is by
shooting in Vancouver it's cheaper to
make the episodes in Vancouver than it
is in Los Angeles and because they were
shooting Supergirl in Los Angeles
that's extra cost on top of the license
fee on top of everything else like the
special effects budget for people that
don't live inside the United States just
in general TV networks typically earn
their money through advertising if it's
really popular they command a much
higher rate so each network has a really
specific target demographic that they go
for in most of the people that were
watching Supergirl worth the people that
CBS was advertising to so from a
production perspective from an audience
perspective the CW is just a much better
fit for Supergirl and because it's made
by the same people that make these other
shows and they want to cross them over
it's just a lot easier to do that too if
all the people that are doing Supergirl
are on a studio lot that sits right next
to where they film the flash and arrow
they actually had a pretty hard time
crossing the flash over with Supergirl
they had to fly Grant Gustin down from
Vancouver so the days that he was
filming the Supergirl crossover they had
to take a break from filming the flash
TV show so the longer that takes the
more production problems that happens so
the really good news now is that it's a
lot easier for them to do a three-night
crossover Supergirl flash than arrow
like they've done the big flash arrow
crossover the last couple of years
Stephen Amell joked that the head of the
CW network was totally down to do a
three-night crossover he was talking
about legends
tomorrow so I'll actually explain a
little bit because his awesome as a
three night crossover would be the the
some of the bad side effects of bringing
Supergirl to CW is that they have to
slash the budget a lot the budget for CW
shows are way less than major Network
shows so what they might do to save
money on Supergirl is just do like 13 or
16 episodes just reduce the episode
count so they can still spend as much
money as they need per episode to do the
special effects all the big action
scenes that doesn't mean it's gonna
solve all their budget problems they're
still gonna have to slash their budget
quite a bit so once they figure things
out behind the scenes they'll probably
announce how many episodes are actually
gonna be in season 2 but I'm expecting
somewhere between 13 and 16 I don't
think they're gonna do the full 20 but I
really do feel like this is the best
possible thing that could have happened
to Supergirl because I feel like the
writers were forced to water down a lot
of the weirdness of DC Comics like some
of the things that make the flash really
awesome I don't think CBS was quite as
excited about taking chances with
stories like that just because Network
shows tend to be watered down for the
lowest common denominator in general so
I'm hoping now that it's moving to the
CW they can just have a little bit more
fun with the characters they can make it
every bit as weird as the flash has been
this season because Supergirl is very
much in the tone of the flash but
hopefully they'll start production on
season 2 during the summer and they'll
have some footage to show off for
comic-con so we'll actually have an idea
of what Supergirl on CW will look like
because for the most part we won't
really know what's going on until they
show it to us but I think visually it
won't look too different
the biggest difference will be in the
types of stories and the types of
characters that they use in the way they
crossover with the other shows so what I
really want to know is if they're gonna
keep Supergirl on a different earth
because that's the way they explain the
crossover this year because CBS was like
this is our show she's gonna be on ours
we don't want to have to address what's
going on in the flash but now that the
CW will own the show there aren't any of
those problems Supergirl can totally
exist on earth one with team flash let
me know in the comments though do you
think they'll try to put her on earth
one with Oliver and Barry I feel like
there is some kind of justice society
episode around the corner whether or not
they actually get to use that name but
they might now that they have a
Supergirl but the other big news they
just announced on legends of tomorrow
captain colt is not going to be a series
regular in season 2 what that means is
that he's not going to be in every
single episode but he will pop up from
time to time
is really funny and it's something that
would only happen in this berlanti verse
of shows that are all connected he
signed an overall contract to be a
series regular on all the TV shows now
what that means is that he's just gonna
be popping up on every single DC show
all season long so he'll be a series
regular meaning that in any given week
he'll be on one of the shows so one week
he might be on the flash the next week
he might be on arrow the other week he
might be on legends of tomorrow he might
even show up on Supergirl but I feel
like this is awesome for Captain cold
it's bad for legends of tomorrow I'll
talk a little bit more about it during
my legends video this week that might
not post until Saturday just because
there's so much stuff that I'm catching
up on if you're wondering why there's
all this TV news today it's because this
is one of the last days for networks to
either cancel or renew TV shows so
there's a whole bunch of stuff that got
cancelled like agent Carter has been
cancelled next big video is going to be
my Voltron video I still have a flash
trailer video to do there's a whole
bunch of stuff so be sure to subscribe
to get everything
while you guys wait for that video to
post you can click here for my
Assassin's Creed trailer video and you
can click here for this week's episode
of the flash thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight